so Rainbow six siege has a couple of new
faces maverick in clash a resident siege
expert Oscar Dias you played with a
couple of them now I have held me about
these new faces well they are both I
would say they're both good operators
good options to have I don't think
either of them are going to be become
essential in the meta but I think
they're both going to be good options to
pick from so maverick is the first he's
an attacker and he comes equipped with a
blowtorch that can essentially burn
through reinforced walls steel and paper
seems like mad powerful yeah so and it
is as well like it's completely silent
unlike thermite Nibbana so he's
definitely a good option a good
alternative to those but the torch
doesn't really burn a big enough hole to
fit through it unless you stay there for
a while
literally carving a hole yeah exactly
and it's not like in the movies where
you cut a hole and then you know you can
kick that all it's like you have you
would have to burn the entire circle in
perfect exactly and so it takes you a
while and so really that's not a viable
option it's more designed for you to be
able to burn a small hole and then peek
through kill a couple of defenders so
that your teammates can attack from
other angles right and he may know the
holes really essentially yeah and I
think it works really well the balance
was hard too I'm not sure whether
whether his balance was perfect or not I
only sort of got to play maybe two hours
also with the new operators so that
remains to be seen but I definitely
think he's a good option the other thing
as well he's completely silent so it's
not like with thermite Habano where you
get a warning if you're a defender with
maverick there isn't pretty much no
warning unless you happen to be looking
at the hole that's being burned through
your defenses and the visual cue from
the other side as well like sparks
fantasy yeah there is a small visual cue
yeah and and the other thing as well as
his combination with glass is amazing
like if you can chuck a couple of smoke
grenades down burn a hole through the
reinforced wall and then glass can use
his thermal sight like it's a lethal
combination so I definitely think glass
is going to benefit
from the introduction of maverick I
think thermite and Havana's pick rate
probably go down although I don't think
even though on the face of it he is an
alternative there to them I think you
probably do still need to be packing one
of those right if you want to be a truly
effective team because Havana's a bit
they they make a much bigger hole in a
bit more dynamic and obviously thermite
as the benefit of actually reaching an
entire wall yeah it kind of fits in that
middle ground somewhere feels exactly
yeah but I do think the effect on the
metal I think will be seen more on the
defensive side because as it stands
maverick doesn't have any counter like
okay so Thatcher sorry thermite and
Habana are completely countered by
bandit or mute unless you know you do
some fancy footwork with Thatcher or
whatever but maverick isn't affected by
bandit or mute so because at all not a
gadget right exactly is is not an
electronic device and so at the moment
like even though I don't think he's like
hugely powerful because the the holes he
creates quite small there is no counter
at the moment so it'll be interesting to
see whether the meta does shift in his
favor and against those of mutant and
bandit which I think mutant particular
is one of my favorite operators and is
my usual go-to like I tend to main mute
on defense so you know unlucky than me I
guess
the barricades that the deployable like
steel barricades can you burn through
those as well as it just the walls ya
know so he can both breach through
reinforced hatches and also through non
reinforced walls as well so the
deployable ones that you set that kind
of triangle ones are they still yeah so
like those ones they've been like
completely reworked because before those
reinforce hatches that the you know you
can reinforce between different floors
they were kind of like a binary thing
before they were like you know it's
either there's a hatch there or it's
been blown away whereas now they've had
to rework that obviously because this is
less of a binary tool like this is you
know
whole gets burned where you're aiming
and so he can burn through those but you
know again it's you're creating your own
hole not you know you don't just put
your boat on it and the whole thing
disappears immediately so they've had to
rework some stuff in the sort of like
background of the game in order to make
that happen but from from the from what
I played you know sort of two or three
hours it worked really well I'm really
interested to see the effect he has on
the metal and I think his the shift
created by him will be far greater than
what's created by clash so clashes the
the new defender and she comes equipped
with essentially it's the shield is very
similar to what mum town has in terms of
its size but she can equip a pistol at
the same time as her shield and that
includes when like there's no option to
extend it or not extend it like there is
was one town it's just it's always
extended but it does have like an
electronic zapper the slows down enemies
and deals a small amount of damage and
although that the range on it is quite
limited and you run out of it's not like
an ammo thing it's like a cool-down okay
meter and although that runs down quite
quickly the slowdown effect is huge like
it really really slows enemies down and
if you get on a one-on-one and you're
against clash like you you're done for
really like you can slow them down so
much and then you can quickly switch to
your pistol to your secondary and and
your enemies done for really
yeah the shield is pretty huge and like
it does feel good so like like she's
very much a support operator like you're
not gonna be there and be able to get
many kills with her but you know as you
can see like she slows enemies down so
much meaning it's such a good Intel
gatherer as well because you can just
stand there yeah and say okay hey mate
was closer that they would been punished
because obviously you can't get into
cover as quickly as they need to exactly
yeah so I'm just at this stage I'm just
creating a distraction for my teammates
to go out there and get the kills for me
and obviously then you get assist points
and so on but like very much like a very
good support operator Intel gatherer
slows enemies down so much like this is
a prime opening
point for the enemies to come into this
room and I've just completely blocked
them here to force them to go another
way which flows and then obviously and
in a ranked game where you only have
what is it three minutes or so yeah like
that's a huge huge boon so I'm thinking
if you had the assistance of what's the
operator that has the anti fancy grenade
saying that the sheep's grenades at the
sky Jager so if you if you had like a
Jaeger turret there that means you're
also like impervious to get nitro bombed
or anything yeah yeah you're you're a
one-man just blocking an area down
yeah and letting your team secure
another area yeah
and I don't think the effects on the
meta from her will be as great as what
it will be with Maverick because I don't
think she sort of she doesn't have the
same kind of interactions with other
operators so well or in terms of their
specific abilities I think she's just
gonna be for me at least I think she's
gonna be my new go-to defender if all of
my mains are taken right like usually I
would play mute or I would play Jaeger
or I play bandit and like if all of
those are taken I would probably go for
rook and you know because you just put a
couple of yeah works pretty awkward yeah
exactly all-purpose and I think she's
gonna be the new rook for me I think
she's just gonna be like a very very
good backup right I don't think she's
gonna become essential obviously the
first couple of weeks after release
everyone's gonna want to play as her but
I think when when everyone's or settles
down I don't think she's gonna be
essential but she will become just a
very very good option yes they're both
certain certain operators right they're
either good with other operators on the
same team or they're super strong on
certain maps whereas I feel like
maverick will be will be excellent
unlike a lot of close quarters in areas
but was it a clash clash clash will be a
pretty good all-rounder on pretty much
every map which is not going to be
amazing anywhere no I don't think so I
don't think so I mean there is the
advantage that she's the only defender
with a shield obviously there's there's
been a number of operators so far
they've had shields but they've all been
attackers so that sort of creates an
interesting new dynamic but yeah
think she's gonna be so I don't think
she's going to become essential once
everyone sort of gets used to her can
she crowd their shields it's quite it's
quite big no you can't Crouch with it I
think you just sit her in front of two
chanko okay the other thing as well is
her shield isn't as effective against
explosives so she is quite easy to
counter if you have explosives and also
you can sort of like melee her shield
out of the way so if someone tries to
melee you when you've got your shield up
it kind of like it gets hit to the side
and so then they can switch back to
their primary or their secondary and
shoot in the gap that has been created
by your shield being moved so I think
she is somewhat easy to counter if you
get up close and personal
or if you have explosives but I think if
you're on a one-on-one with her I think
you're really really gonna struggle
because that slowdown effect is so so
good yeah but I'm really interested to
see what happens when she gets into the
hands of players who are much better at
siege than I am yeah there's always
something unexpected going on as soon as
new operators get released when you know
like the pros play or the eSports scene
playing but like I said I'll be
interested in to see how the the Met
shifts and whenever there's new opera is
a new map I always kind of want to let
my toes and dip back into siege but
exactly and I should say as well the the
new Herefords a siz completely different
to the old Hereford base like it's
completely unrecognizable
I had no idea where I was going and it's
a very confusing layout but it's
definitely I think gonna be a lot better
there's a noose of stairs there's new
entry points the bomb sites have been
completely rejigged consulate has had a
buff as well so a couple of the bomb
sites there have been reject consulate
is largely the same but Hereford base is
completely different and I'm really
looking forward to playing it when I
actually know that they hacked well that
it all sounds like super fascinating and
again hearing you talk about the new
operators has made me want to play siege
again but for every other bit of siege
content that you want stay tuned to game
spot
the last operator standing for
elimination
friendly mission successful
[Music]